over the course of a decade in change
Michael C Hall starred on two of the
most critically acclaimed television
series in recent memory both of them
aboutdeath
he played David Fisher on HBO's family
run funeral home drama Six Feet Under
and then vigilante serial killer Dexter
Morgan on Showtime's Dexter between the
two shows howl amassed six Emmy and five
Golden Globe nominations and one Golden
Globe win for his performances yeah well
the tricky the tricky thing about Dexter
is I look so much like him but with the
end of Dexter in 2013 Hall has been
largely absent from TV here's a look at
what he's been up to in the past few
years curtain call Hall is an
experienced theatrical actor after
completing the Graduate acting program
in New York University's prestigious
Tisch School of the Arts all landed the
plum role of EMC in director Sam Mendes
of 1999 revival of cabaret on Broadway
while on a hiatus from six feet under in
2002 he portrayed shady lawyer Billy
Flynn in the long-running revival of the
musical Chicago when Dexter concluded in
2013 Hall again had the time to return
to the stage one of his most notable
roles was in Hedwig and the Angry Inch a
glam rock musical about an East German
transgender wannabe rock star Paul was
the third actor to play the title role
on Broadway following Neil Patrick
Harris and Andrew Reynolds channeling
Bowie
all next major theatrical role was
Thomas Newton in Lazarus a musical
co-created by David Bowie just before
his death in 2016
built around previously existing Bowie
songs as well as ones that have yet to
be released Lazarus was presented by the
New York Theatre Workshop from late 2015
to early 2016
all reprise his role when the sold-out
show moved to London when Bowie died
unexpectedly just before the Lazarus
cast recorded the show's album all said
that he felt an internal fist clinch but
the cast decided to continue the work in
his honour we were glad that we were
able to get together and celebrate his
life by recording the album voice work
outside of stage and screen Dexter has
used his vocal talents to do some voice
work here and there all has had a
recurring role on the light-hearted
Disney XD sci-fi fantasy series star
versus the forces of evil
it was probably Hall's most comic role
to date he voiced an evil reptile named
toffee eat something
could be your last meal a little closer
to his wheelhouse of dark brooding men
Hall played Batman and Justice League
gods and monsters with some lines that
will probably bring on deja vu for
Dexter fans he bled to death
yes except they can't find the blood
indie movie since the end of Dexter Hall
has popped up in a handful of low
profile but critically acclaimed
independent films he starred in cold in
July taking the role of a man who kills
a burglar and then must deal with the
man's father who's out for revenge
all followed up that screen role with
yet another project revolving around
death Christine about a deeply unstable
Florida news anchor Michael C Hall
played George a potential love interest
in fellow news anchor married life in
February 2016 Hall took some time to
catch up on his personal life at New
York City Hall he and Morgan McGregor
his partner of four years tied the knot
which marked Hall's third trip down the
aisle in the early 2000s he married his
Chicago co-star actress Amy spanger and
later got hitched to Jennifer Carpenter
who played his sister Deb on Dexter
Radiohead obsessed
[Music]
in 2016 Hall and fellow Hedwig and the
Angry Inch star Lena Hall teamed up to
perform at a Radiohead tribute concert
called Radiohead obsessed the band they
formed was a one-time-only thing turning
out a performance at new york's cafe
Carlyle the songs they played included
rip cord from Radiohead 1993 debut LP
Pablo Honey as well as the mash-up of
songs from Radiohead's 1995 follow up
the bends upcoming projects Paul will be
back on screens big and small very soon
over the last couple of years he's
filmed appearances in three high-profile
projects all has joined the second
season cast of Netflix's Queen Elizabeth
the second drama the crown portraying
president John F Kennedy another project
the silent man is a thriller about the
Watergate scandal starting Liam Neeson
as Mark felt the high-ranking FBI
official who leaked details of the
scandal to the Washington Post under the
name deep throat in that film Paul has a
major role as John Dean the lawyer who
served as white House Counsel during the
sinking Nixon administration and finally
he's slated to appear in the Gettysburg
Address a documentary about President
Abraham Lincoln's most famous speech
sounds like there's life after Dexter
after all nothing to hide except for the
syringes scalpels and bone saw hidden in
that secret drawer underneath thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]